ما في احلى من انه يجي يوم ويتكلم فيه
الانسان على اشياء عاملها بالحياه بخصوصا
اذا كانت هل اعمال مميزه وصنعت تاريخ لا
ينسى بس كيف اذا كانت تكريم كمان ضمن
فعاليات موسم الرياض هذا اللي صار العميد
لاعبي العالم صاحب المسيره الرياضيه
الخارج عن المقلوب الطبيعه طبعا واللي
بيعجز اللسان عن وصفه واساطير كثيره حكت
عن مسيرته وظل لاكثر من عقدين عم يصنع
المعنى الحقيقي للاعجاز الكرهوي مين غيره
الايقونه ماذا عبد الله تكريم ماجد عبد
الله كان بمسرحيه السهم الملتهب اللي كانت
ضمن الموسم الرياضي وجاءت اتكلم غيث الى
جسد رحله الاسطوره لكن قبل ما ندخل
بتفاصيل مسرحيه خلونا مشاهدينا نسترجع
سواء اجمل الاهداف اللي حققها ماجد عبد
الله بن مسيرته الرياضيه الحافيه
يوسف خميس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شوف شوف ماجد عدى من المدافع وغطى على
يسار حاره المرمى يا حبيبي يا ماجد يا
سلام يا ماجد شوف
هذا ماجد عبد الله هذا ماجد عبد الله شوف
عدى عد
ى من كره سريعه
لا يعرف
مركز الكره
[ضحك]
[تصفيق]
هدفاته اول كوره يستلمها لعبه سريعه
وطويله في اتجاه ماجد عبدالله ماجد باجري
ومعها ايمن الحسيني
ارضيه المهلل مهلل
[تصفيق]
شايفين ماجد انطلقوا وعمل نفس الاسلوب ما
هو على المكيني
[تصفيق]
الى قلب المرمى الكويتي يعلن تاهل المنتخب
السعودي
وحقته بتمثيل المجموعه الخامسه في
التصفيات النهائيه لاسيا هل همم بطوله كاس
العالم الف مبروك لمنتخبنا الف مبروك
لكره ماجد شايفين دخل فيها وهو على الحارس
عموما المسرحيه اللي انتهى عرضها مؤخرا
كانت روعه بشاهده الجمهور الحاضر واستعرضت
ابرز محطات ماجد عبد الله اللي قام بتاديه
دوره الممثل السعودي فيصل الدوخي اللقاء
في تصريحات للعربيه انه الدور كان من اصعب
الادوار في حياته وينها تحضيرات العرض
بدات قبل شهر دوخي ما اكتفى بنص المسرحي
وراح ابعد واستعاند المواد المتاحه على
الانترنت حتى يتعرف على الطباع وابعاد
ماجد الشخصيه اكثر وهذا يا جماعه بحداته
خير دليل على قديش شخصيه الاسطوره ماجد
عبدالله فريده دوخي كشف للعربيه ناس كمان
عن اتصالات مع ماجد واللي كانت بتدور حول
طريق التصرفه مع عائلته مع اصدقائه واكثر
من هيك كمان الدوخي ركز خلال الاجتماع مع
اللاعب على سلوكيات وتحركاته الجسديه وردت
فعله وقال انه وجه تحدي كبير بكيفيه نقل
الهدوء ماجد للمسرح واصاله الجمهور
طبعا انا هلا مش عارفه كيف راح اقدم ضيفي
هل اقول مثلا هو السهم الملتهب اللي هو
طبعا مسجد عبد الله او ممثل السهم الملتهب
الفنان السعودي فيصل الدوخي راح اترك
الاجابه له قبل ما ابدا طبعا اسئله كثيره
اهلا وسهلا فيك
عبد الله كان على المسرح يعني
كيف كانت تجربتك في اداءها انت ذكرت بانه
كانت من اصعب الادوار اللي اديتها هل
بداياتها كان كنت تعتبرها على على الاقل
حتى لو بداخلك لانه كانت مغامره كبيره همم
يعني في هذه المرحله من مسيرتك
والله فعلا هي مغامره طبعا هي بدات فكره
المسرحيه هي جات من معالي المستشار تركي
ال الشيخ
واعلن عنها في الاعلام يعني السنه اللي
فاتته تعتقد او بدايه او بدايه 22 وانا
سمعت الاعلان كان في برنامج رياضي كان
موجود مع المستشار وكان على يمين الكابتن
يوسف الثنيان وقال ان في الربع الاول من
23 راح يكون في مسرحيه للكابتن يوسف
ومسرحيه الكابتن ماجد عبد الله همم بس ما
شاء الله يعني معالي دائما همم في كل شيء
سريع والانجاز عند قبل موعد همم المقرر
يعني احنا في الربع الرابع من 22 وبس
راحتين تنفذه الحمد لله فكلمني المنتج
بشكل رسمي انه حب يشارك وهمم شاركت معهم
الفكره كانت في الاساس اني انا راح ادي
دور ماجد عبد الله في فتره الشباب فقط
ولكن لما جينا اول يوم قراءه الطاوله وكذا
لقينا المفترض انه يلعب دور كبير ولازم
شخص ثاني يلعب دور ماجد عبد الله الشاب
الممثل عبد الرحمن المزين بحكم التغييرات
والتبديل في الميك اب والهمم الملابس ما
في تايم تلازم ممثلين
وكانت صعبه بالنسبه لي اني اخذ شخصيه ماجد
عبد الله الفتره الحاليه ولكن يوم رحت
وجلست معه وتكلمت معه همم
وهو كان سهل للموضوع كان يقول لي لا تفكر
باي شيء اهم شيء انت كويس ولا تفكر في اي
شيء لا تفكر بشكل لا تفكر ماشي لا تفكر بس
انا حاربت ان احنا نروح ونقرب نسبه 60 70%
بالفعل يدرس هذا الدور من كل الجوانبه
هذه الدراسه من المعلم الاصلي يعني صاحب
الشخصيه الاصليه ولكن انا سمعت انك يعني
شويه تعبته
اتصالات كثير واجتماعات كثير واسئله
وتفاصيل كثير يعني ان شاء الله بتكون
تعبته كثير
انا متاح يعني ما قصروا وقف معنا الكابتن
ماجد سواء انا او ماجد الشاب او ماجد
الصغير والمخرج ايضا كنا نرجع لها بشئه
كثيره ولكن ما قصر معنا باي شيء وانا
حاولت اني ما ازعجتك كثير همم واكثر شيء
بدري في ايام العروض كان موجود يوميا يحضر
وكان حريص ان بعد العرض يجينا ويقول ترى
انت قلت كده والصح انك تسوي كذا ثاني
اعطيني تنبيهات يوميا يعني
ملاحظات يعني على الاداء حتى تتحسن يعني
على همم كل يوم
بالضبط هذا اللي سواه الكابتن ماجد وهو
يسوي تمثيل معايا المفروض فهو اللي سواء
الكابتن ماجد معي كان يجي يقول لي ترى كذا
المعلومه هذه لازم تنقال بالطريقه هذه
مش بس الكابتن ماجد
[موسيقى]
اكتر عن ردود الفعل بعد عرض المسرحيه يعني
الحقيقه شوهد لها بانها كانت جميله جدا من
الحاضرين انت كيف كيف وجدت تقبل الجمهور
للمسرحيه وخصوصا انه المسرح يعني مش مش
سهل همم
وصوله للمتلقي مثل التلفزيون ومثل همم
السينما خصوصا لا شخصيات مثل شخصيه ماجد
عبدالله
الفريق الافراج بقياده نهايه البقمي
وفريق الممثلين كلهم يعني حاولوا ممكن
يقدر عليه احنا اول عرض كان عندنا كلنا
خائفين منها لان الكابتن ماجد اسرته موجود
فعلهم هم قبل الجمهور
وكانوا مبسوطين الحمد لله هذا اعطانا ثقه
ان احنا نروح بشكل اطول جماهير بالعروض
المتتاليه بعدها رده فعل الجمهور جدا
رائعه الناس بعد العرض قاعدين يثنون على
العرض بشكل كبير وهذا الحمد لله بفضل الله
همم لما وقفناها رساله كثير جاتني زعلانين
يعني كان اخر عرض هو امس قبل امس فكانوا
زعلانين ناس يرسلوا لي ان احنا نبغى نجي
واحنا ما امدانا وما حصلنا تكت بس ان شاء
الله اكيد في خطه في الموسم او نهايه عادي
يعني بتتكرروا
طيب يعني حبيت هيك سؤال فضولي اعرف انو
افضل او اجمل الاهداف برايك يعني
للكابتن ماجد عبدالله
المنتخب الصين
واذا كان السؤال على اجمل هدف
اذا اذا
متاكد من التاريخ
84 كامله
ايه لما يمكن النصراوي
احد جاب هدف ولكن
تراه مو هدف يا جماعه راح الحكم قال له
تراني ما جبته
يعني اقدر اجيب هدف حقيقي
هلالي او على الاقل يمكن عشان ولدك عبد
الله الهلال
انا انا ماني مشجع انا مالي في الكوره
يعني يمكن تقريبا من ثمانيه الى 10 سنوات
ولكن عندي ابني عبد الله وبنت عائشه يحبون
الهلال فانا عشانهم قالوا لي لازم
اغيرهم يقول لهم انا بغير
العائله كلها تتمتع بروح رياضيه
عبد الله وعن النصر
كانوا مبسوطين بهذه الاسطوره
وفخر لك همم لكل همم الجمهور السعوديه
شكرا جزيلا لكم نتمنى لك كل التوفيق
وبنتمنى انك تتمد مسرحيه حتى يتسنى المزيد
من همم طبعا الناس انه يحضروها ويشوفوا
هالمسيره الجميله للرائعه طبعا همم
الاسطوره ماجد عبد الله شكرا جزيلا لك
الفنان السعودي فيصل الدوخي